ben affleck is opening up about his
rekindled romance with jennifer lopez
this is a thrill i can't stop smiling
the 49 year old oscar winner covers wsj
magazine's december january issue and
gets candid about the kind of man he
wants to be noting that for years fear
drove him to have a strong work ethic
but now he's more focused on himself and
his kids sixteen-year-old violet
twelve-year-old seraphina and
nine-year-old samuel whom he shares with
his ex-wife jennifer garner quote the
most important thing is being a good
father the second most important thing
is to be a good man and a good person
and ostensibly you know a good husband
hopefully yeah you heard the man he said
husband people you know ostensibly it
feels really good and it's really nice
but i'm so happy of course jen and ben
famously known as benifer recently
reignited their flame 17 years after
they called off their engagement in
2004. it was my first like adult
heartbreak we were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just
a bad heartbreak and ben he says their
story is extra special in fact he says
their renewed relationship is quote
beautiful quote it is a good story it's
a great story and you know maybe one day
i'll tell it i'll write it all out and
then i'll light it on fire but don't
expect ben to dish more deets on his
relationship with a 52 year old triple
threat quote one of the harder lessons
that i have learned is that it's not
wise to share everything with the world
and while the last dual star may not be
weighing in on his relationship his
bestie matt damon told et back in
october they have his seal of approval
it's great
it's wonderful and uh i'm just happy to
see uh see my friend really happy but
that same night ben played coy when
asked about his leading lady i don't
know if you are aware of how good the
internet thinks you look it's like all
everyone's talking about lately i think
you might be no i'm not
i'm really not ben um i is it the jlo
glow like how much happiness is she
bringing into your life because you're
looking good man is it the corduroy is
that when she was like you're big on the
quarter because i wasn't sure about
where they told me it's fall and while
ben was staying tight-lipped about his
personal life a source tells e.t the
lovebirds are planning on spending
christmas together and want to make it
as special as they can for the kids
i'm thrilled i am really happy jlo of
course shares 13 year old twins max and
emmy with her ex mark anthony quote they
want all the kids to be together for the
holiday if possible and do something
just the two of them as well jen has
always loved christmas and cannot wait
to spend it with ben she's excited
[Music]
you